buonasera a tutti
circa 35 anni fa più o meno 34 1979 mi
trovavo ad arezzo al teatro petrarca
mi hanno detto che il teatro guido
monaco non esiste ad arezzo per cui la
mia memoria ha avuto un attimo di di
défaillance e mi trovavo con il coro
minatori santa barbara di massa
marittima al concorso per musica
polifonica intestato a guido monaco
vi saranno venute le già mente un paio
di considerazioni la prima è che fine
hanno fatto i capelli del vostro speaker
e la seconda è perché ho cominciato a
parlarvi qui mostrando un coro ho
cominciato così perché la la sensazione
che si prova cantando in coro è
indescrivibile da un punto di vista
fisico ed è basata sul concetto di
risonanza cioè la voce come tutti
qualsiasi tipo di strumento musicale si
trasmette nell'aria attraverso delle
oscillazioni fatte dalla rarefazione
dalla compressione delle appunto della
dell'area che fanno le onde sonore e
queste oscillazioni si riverberano
all'interno dei coristi che cantiamo
tutti cantavano tutti uno accanto
all'altro producendo una sensazione
fisica straordinaria che favorisce e
contribuiva anche alla particolare
emozione che avevamo tutti in quel
momento lì anche i nostri neuroni
producono delle correnti e delle
correnti di tipo oscillatori queste
correnti possono essere registrate dalla
superficie della nostra testa attraverso
ne avrete sicuramente sentito parlare
l'elettroencefalogramma e vedete che
tutti questi segnali oscillatori che
direi rappresentano un codice
incredibilmente sofisticato di
comunicazione fra questi gruppi di
network di
neuronali sono molto complesse e sono
formate da una serie di oscillazioni di
base che vengono identificate attraverso
la seconda del loro periodo vedete 5
oscillazioni al secondo 10 l'azione al
secondo 20 30 con delle lettere greche
del dell'alfabeto quindi peta sono le
oscillazioni più lente alfa e beta
quelle intermedie gamma le oscillazioni
quelle a frequenza più elevata
questo stesso tipo di oscillazioni
alteta alfa beta e gamma siamo in grado
di produrre di produrle dall'esterno
sulla superficie della nostra testa in
modo del tutto non invasivo concorrenti
impercettibili dai soggetti di
bassissima intensità
un milan perde anche meno e possiamo
essere in grado di produrre di fornire
al nostro cervello attraverso degli
elettrodi o dei caschetti particolari
quindi la corrente con oscillazioni che
noi vogliamo nella regione che vogliamo
o simultaneamente nelle regioni che noi
vogliamo che cosa succede nel nostro
cervello quando forniamo questo tipo di
corrente oscillatore un fenomeno che si
chiama entra in mente trascinamento
dovete pensare ad un neurone con come un
singolo elemento oscillante quindi per
esempio 3 neuroni che oscillano in modo
un po anarchico ognuno in una direzione
particolare quando questi gruppi di
neuroni sono sottoposti ad una forza
esterna che in questo caso è la nostra
corrente oscillante che applichiamo
tendono a sincronizzarsi fra di loro
cioè ad avere quello che si chiama un
allineamento di fase delle oscillazioni
ea produrre un progressivo incremento di
ampiezza del ritmo che noi stiamo
intercettando è un po quello che succede
per chi suona qualche strumento perché
suona chitarra quando accordiamo la
chitarra che premendo la corda
into capo tasto fa sì che risuoni e
produciamo la notare e fa sì che la
corda del re cominci ad oscillare in
modo consono con quella che stiamo
pizzicando oppure per chi non è un
musicista e che si occupa di sport
potrebbe essere un buon esempio quello
di una barca in cui gli otto rematori
devono sono sincronizzati a remare allo
stesso modo dal dal dal capo buca e così
la barca va più veloce è chiaro che se
il ritmo cerebrale che a questo modo io
riesco a modulare riesco a modificare
sostiene è necessario per una
determinata funzione cerebrale
il suo potenziamento produrrà
probabilmente una modifica della sua
della prestazione in quel tipo di tusk
in questo modo con questo approccio noi
ma anche altri gruppi nel mondo
ovviamente siamo stati in grado di
modulare differenti aspetti differenti
tasca di tipo mentale cognitivo
per esempio è possibile migliorare
alcuni aspetti di percezione tattile
l'esplorazione tattile applicando delle
correnti alternate in banda alfa cioè
quelle di oscillazione intermedia siamo
stati in gradi di interferire con alcuni
aspetti legati al movimento volontario
utilizzando che ho fatto utilizzando
delle correnti in banda meta oppure per
esempio utilizzando delle correnti un po
più lente in banda teta siamo stati in
grado di modificare di migliorare
transitoriamente alcuni aspetti legati a
processi di memoria in soggetti normali
o ancora utilizzando un ritmo alpha
nelle aree visive alcuni colleghi sono
stati in grado di migliorare alcuni
aspetti della percezione visiva
noi ci siamo spinti un pochino un
pochino coltre diciamo abbiamo
pubblicato un lavoro
lo scorso anno e abbiamo cercato di
migliorare e cercare di migliorare
alcuni aspetti legati a quello che si
chiama intelligenza fluida per capire
cos'è l'intelligenza secondo me è
fondamentale rifarsi a questa
definizione di regista mario monicelli
su che cos'è il genio fantasia
immaginazione colpo d'occhio e velocità
di esecuzione esemplificato del film
amici miei dalla creazione istantanea
delle degli scherzi che facevano questo
gruppo di amici ovviamente in un
contesto sperimentale abbiamo dovuto
adattare il task di intelligenza fluida
e abbiamo utilizzato la soluzione di
queste che si chiamano matrici di ravel
che è un giochino cognitivo che è
sotteso da un ragionamento di tipo
logico molto profondo e si tratta di
trovare la soluzione a questa serie di
nove di nove elementi scegliendola fry e
fra gli elementi a disposizione
qui sotto abbiamo sottoposto una
sessantina di soggetti a questo tipo di
tusk durante una stimolazione alternata
indifferenti bande di frequenza sulla
regione prefrontale di sinistra e quello
che abbiamo trovato è questo
in queste barre rosse vedete se il tempo
necessario ai soggetti per risolvere
correttamente questo tipo di tusk e
questo tempo si riduce di circa il 20
per cento che non è poco in ambito
cognitivo in ambito in ambito cerebrale
ma la cosa interessante è che non si
riduce in modo uguale in tutti i
soggetti cioè chi era già abbastanza
rapido e fast performance in condizioni
basali non ha avuto nessun beneficio
della stimolazione mentre quelli che
erano più lenti sono proprio quelli che
hanno migliorato questo apre delle
prospettive etiche rilevanti perché è un
po un modo per diciamo azzerare comunque
ridurre le ineguaglianze cognitive che
ci sono trame fra
ognuno di voi però se voi pensate che
questo tipo di approccio e potrebbe
essere utilizzato per esempio in uno
studente un ragazzino che ha dei
disturbi di tipo attentivo all'interno
di una classe in cui invece altre
persone non hanno questi disturbi
potrebbe essere un modo per aiutare
questo ragazzino o per aiutare anche
presente soggetti anziani che cominciano
ad avere dei disturbi di tipo di di
memoria questo approccio che vi ho
presentato e un approccio abbastanza di
frontiera nel campo della
neuromodulazione che per altri versi è
già una realtà clinica per alcune
malattie di tipo neurologico e
psichiatrico cronico che prevedono anche
degli interventi di tipo chirurgico
grazie dell'attenzione